so in the mid-90s in Miami a few people
figured hey we'll kidnap torture and
murder people and now Michael Bay
figures he'll make a movie that's a
comedy that makes light of that
situation and makes you the viewer root
for the who did all that
weird doesn't quite cover that pain and
gay so painting gained stars Mark
Wahlberg Dwayne the rock Johnson in his
like fifth movie this year and that one
other dude that dude I don't know his
name maybe that makes me a dick but I
don't know his name their weightlifters
they're bodybuilders and they're like
we're tired of being poor so like Tony
Shalhoub tan we'll kidnap him
will torture him we'll have him sign
over all those assets to us live is good
this is one of those movies this is a
difficult movie to talk about because
this situation did happen but these guys
were dicks they were all
accounts says that there were very
violent people who killed people so I'll
touch on those points later on in this
video but for right now let's review the
movie as a movie as a movie it's a
pretty sloppy movie you like the rock he
was really good in the movie I would
argue he's one of the best parts of the
movie hands down best person best role
best character in this entire movie Ed
Harris he's one of those private
investigator types he's like all right
yeah I'll find out what happened to you
Tony Shalhoub because you look like
you've been through and they
obviously did something to you however
this movie's edited really weird you're
like is it funny is it supposed to be a
comedy it's obviously been marketed as a
comedy in the trailer so you know you're
supposed to be watching a dark comedy
but the fact is Michael Bay just doesn't
know how to do comedy he proved that
with the Transformers movies now Michael
Bay is like no I can do comedy I proved
that with transformers the people who
said I can't do comedy they don't know
what they're talking about let me prove
it to you by making a comedy about a
real-life murder story a murder that
happened not too long ago so the
families of the victims are still alive
good you know it's not a real murder
comedy unless you've enraged the living
family of the victim it was edited
really choppy everyone has voiceover in
this movie Mark Wahlberg has his voice
over in which he tells his first-person
perspective of what's going on so does
everybody else do you like the movies
about everybody in which is about nobody
really a movie has to be focused this
movie if I can describe it in one word
it's unfocused just everywhere it's all
over the place you're here then you're
there and the color scheme is all messed
up yeah making your movie look like this
doesn't make it
better it's now a really choppy movie
with blown-out color and contrast I was
actually looking forward to pain and
gain I thought it would be the return of
Michael Bay that I liked at one point I
remember liking bad boys too and I saw
it
eons ago but watching movies now that
are made by Michael Bay make me question
whether or not bad boys 2 is even good
what I do know is this Michael Bay now
wasn't the Michael Bay we always had
there was a director his name was
Michael Bay he made the movie the rock
and then aliens sucked up that Michael
Bay and replaced him with a changeling
who has done everything else that's the
only way I can describe it that's what
happened that's why Michael Bay always
makes movies about aliens Dwayne the
rock Johnson and Mark Wahlberg seem to
have fun with the roles and that ain't
bad in a movie but that brings us to our
next point this movie is based on a
real-life case about kidnapping torture
murder all that he protagonists in
this movie in real life kidnapped a guy
tortured him for a month until he signed
over all his assets to them in the
course of this entire adventure in the
movie they killed a couple people they
are murderers they actually did this
in the movie cops out because
they're like well you can't actually
root for murderers in the movie so we
make it accidental death I mean I almost
feel like I'm giving you spoilers in
this movie but it's just they're bad
guys they're bad guys made to look like
good guys so you look at the movie
payback with Mel Gibson he was a bad guy
the catchphrase for the movie is get
ready to root for the bad guy but he was
still like he was a bad guy who was dict
over by worse bad guys so he's the bad
guy you want to root for because he's
kind of a cool bad guy I guess the
parallel situation would be like making
a biographical picture about OJ Simpson
directed by Michael bank called
be crazy the catchphrase could be
be crazy and crazy gotta go or
the biggest slash stick comedy of the
year it's just you would see that and be
like I don't know if that's the best way
to go about this and it's not making a
situation like this a comedy isn't good
if they made it like the movie blow that
would be interesting it's like oh yeah
this really happened and now is
presented as the drama and if it was
done well I'd be interested to be like
okay wow that's interesting that that
should happen sucks that it happen but
we're entertained by it and it does the
situation justice yeah they said Texas
Chainsaw Massacre is based on a true
story but if you look at the real story
it's not actually based on a true story
the story that's based off of is so far
separated it's not really like that
and even then Leatherface was still the
bad guy turning a real-life situation
like this into a
comedy in which the bad guys are
actually the good guys you're supposed
to root for now that's just going to
make you look like an if you're
going to make a movie like this a comedy
a movie that's about murder that's based
on real murders that happen in which the
families of the victims are still alive
and remember the situation make it funny
the movies not funny Michael Bay really
rolled the dice on this I'll give him
credit for the balls he's like I'm gonna
make this movie a comedy all right man
hope you succeed well you didn't upon
all that as a movie the movie is
entertaining to a point it is a bit too
long in that Michael Bay way every
Michael Bay movie or like could have
been a half an hour shorter I can't dog
this one up on principle I do want
to but I can't as a movie it's not
actually dog but I will say you're
not gonna remember this movie in t-minus
one day yep already forgot I so pain and
gain have you seen it do you think it
was a good call to make this movie a
comedy do you think I should have been
done as a drama I think we can all agree
it would have been better done in other
hands whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more